rugby prides itself on inclusivity
regardless of gender size or sexuality
from the grassroots like these women in
North London to the elite level but now
rugby is wrestling the thorniest issue
in sport
how do transgender players those who
have switched from male to female or
vice versa fit in world rugby the
sport's governing body is concerned its
current eligibility rules could be
putting all the women at risk
they're holding a groundbreaking two-day
forum where scientists lawyers and
advocacy groups will debate the issue
Verity Smith continued to play for all
the room ladies while transitioning to
being a man now he fears transgender
players could be excluded what would you
say to people who say in women's rugby
it's dangerous I don't think it's
dangerous as I say Sport is for
everybody I've had to play women they're
over a foot taller than me I'm about to
play women they're a lot bigger size
wise than me so why would it be a danger
we all go into spa and rugby
specifically knowing it's a contact
sport and when you look at the
international games look at your
scrum-half look at your second rose over
a foot and a half difference sometimes a
recent Swedish University study suggests
benefits for transgender women continued
even after taking testosterone
suppressants pressure groups say it's
dangerous if we ignore the difference of
in strength between trans women and
women that will put women at risk in
terms of safety on the pitch as well as
fairness in sport so you know there's
there's a worry here that people will be
you know next will get broken
there'll be concussion issues the safety
issues for but rugby are immense and we
just can't ignore them this meeting in
South West London will involve anyone
who's anyone in the debate around
transgender participation in sport it
will affect not just what happens on
rugby pictures in this country but
around the world
some within the sport say there are far
more transgender players than are known
about around the country making this
debate essential this just add to that
wider debate about safety in rugby so it
it's very very important that world
rugby
take this issue and it's very very
important that they're there leading the
discussion and be interesting to see how
other sports might follow the revised
guidelines will take weeks or even
months to decide upon with such a
fiendishly difficult and divisive issue
world rugby is putting itself on the
front foot Martha Kellner Sky News